Speaker 1: All right, let's start today with
a covid update, we haven't done this for a
while, and increasingly the numbers in the
United States are looking better and better
as vaccination takes place.
We've seen the slowdown due to vaccine hesitancy.
We will talk about it.
We have also now seen evidence that the vaccines
work well enough against all major variants.
We will talk about that momentarily.
But first of all, cases, cases which peaked
at more than two hundred and fifty five thousand
cases per day in mid-January, an outrageous
number, not illegal, but certainly an immoral
number.
As I like to say, cases are now down under
50000 thousand cases per day for the first
time since October of twenty twenty.
It's been seven months since cases have been
this low, down to about 47000 per day as of
yesterday.
This is now down more than 80 percent from
the peak in mid-January.
And these numbers should continue down and
look even better by Memorial Day, certainly
by mid-June.
As far as deaths go, deaths peaked in late
January at nearly thirty five hundred deaths
per day, more than a 9/11 every single day.
And those are now also down more than 80 percent
to about six seventy five a day.
Still horrible, but dramatically lower.
And understand that daily deaths in the US
have not been below 700 a day since July of
last summer.
So that is going very much in the right direction.
Deaths as low as they've been in basically
10 months now.
Globally, cases were coming down and are coming
down in the US globally.
We did see a spike led by countries like India
and Brazil, among others, that has also turned
around not by much, but globally.
Cases are now down about three to four percent
from the peak that happened about 10 days
ago.
We hope that the global numbers will also
start coming down more significantly as vaccines
get to more and more countries.
And we will speak momentarily about Joe Biden
coming out in support of lifting or not enforcing
patents on vaccines.
I actually don't think that's going to make
a difference, but I'm going to tell you why
in the next segment.
Earlier this week, I did tell you that vaccination
is a growing problem in the sense that supply
is now exceeding demand in many places.
And we've seen average daily doses decline
from their high of about three point four
million a day now down to just two point one
million doses per day over the last week.
That's not good, but it will still get us
where we need to go as long as it continues.
But the decline in doses led Joe Biden to
announce a new vaccination initiative earlier
this week.
We talked about it yesterday.
CVS Pharmacy has already met the call.
They are going to be offering walk in vaccination,
no appointment necessary at thousands of pharmacies
across the country.
But the really good news about vaccines is
they work on the variance of concern.
Dr. Eric Topol, former guest on the show,
published yesterday, a great infographics
showing us that of all of the relevant variants
so far, there's the British, South African
and Brazilian.
Then there's the New York, California and
India variants.
We have at least some evidence that the vaccines
work, for example, with the UK, South Africa
and Brazil variants.
We now have lab studies, randomized clinical
trials and real world evidence that the vaccines
work well enough on those variants, that if
we keep vaccinating, we can get out of this
for the New York, California and India variants.
We don't yet have the randomized controlled
trials, but we have lab studies and we have
real world evidence.
So we have a path out of this.
Moderna and Fizer at minimum, are working
on Booster's that will be tweaked for the
variance for the fall or winter.
So the path is clear by Memorial Day.
We will have a better situation than we have
today and a little deeper, you know, early
summer, it will be even better if people keep
getting vaccinated.
Let's talk next about
the patents.